>>> WE ARE GETTING A NEW INSIDE
LOOK AT WHAT LIFE WAS LIKE FOR
THE GENERALS WHO TOOK THEIR
ORDERS FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IN OUR FIRST LOOK OF A NEW BOOK
WRITTEN BY SUSAN GLASSER AND
ROBERT BAKER THEY DESCRIBE THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS OF
STAFF GENERAL MARK MILLEY
TALKING TO THE PRESIDENT BEFORE
TALKING THE TRACH JOB AND IT
ASSURED HIM, MR. PRESIDENT, YOU
WILL BE MAKING DEET
SIGNIFICANCES, I CAN GUARANTEE
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU AN HONEST
ANSWER.
I WILL GIVE YOU AN HONEST ANSWER
ON EVERYTHING I CAN AND YOU ARE
GOING TO MAKE THE DECISIONS AND
AS LONG AS THEY'RE LEGAL I WILL
SUPPORT IT.
AS LONG AS THEY'RE LEGAL, IT WAS
NOT CLEAR HOW MUCH THAT CAVEAT
EVEN REGISTERED WITH TRUMP.
JOINING US NOW IS SUSAN GLASSER,
CNN GLOBAL AFFAIRS ANALYST AND
STAFF WRITER AT THE NEW YORKER
THE CO-USER OF "THE DIVIDER"
BILLED AS THE INSIDE STORY OF
THE FOUR YEARS WHEN DONALD TRUMP
WENT TO WAR WITH WASHINGTON.
SUSAN, I REALLY WANT TO GET TO
YOU SPEAKING ABOUT YOUR BOOK BUT
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT MAY BE
THE MOST INTERESTING PART OF IT,
WHICH IS THE RESIGNATION LETTER
THAT MARK MILLEY WROTE BUT
DIDN'T SEND.
I'M GOING TO READ A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT SO THAT YOU CAN SPEAK
ABOUT IT.
THIS WAS DRAFTED IN JUNE OF 2020
AFTER WHAT HAPPENED IN
WASHINGTON OUTSIDE THE WHITE
HOUSE WITH THE USE OF THE
MILITARY.
AND HE SAID, IT IS MY BELIEF
THAT YOU WERE DOING GREAT AND
IRREPARABLE HARM TO MY COUNTRY.
I BELIEVE THAT YOU HAVE MADE A
CONCERTED EFFORT OVER TIME TO
POLITICIZE THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY.
I THOUGHT THAT I COULD CHANGE
THAT.
I'VE COME TO THE REALIZATION
THAT I CAN'T.
HE GOES ON TO SAY, YOU ARE USING
THE MILITARY TO CREATE FEAR IN
THE MINDS OF THE PEOPLE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TRUST THEIR
MILITARY AND THEY TRUST US TO
PROTECT THEM AGAINST ALL
ENEMIES, FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC,
AND OUR MILITARY WILL DO JUST
THAT.
AND HE SAID, THIRD, I SWORE AN
OATH TO THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES THAT SAYS ALL MEN
AND WOMEN ARE CREATED EQUAL.
HE SAYS, IT'S OBVIOUS TO ME THAT
YOU DON'T HOLD THOSE VALUES DEAR
AND THE CAUSE THAT I SERVE.
AND LASTLY, HE SAID, IT IS MY
DEEPLY-HELD BELIEF THAT YOU ARE
RUINING THE INTERNATIONAL ORDER,
WHICH WAS INSTITUTED IN 1949.
HE SAYS, YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE WAR WAS ABOUT, IN FACT,
YOU SUBSCRIBE TO MANY OF THE
PRINCIPLES THAT WE FOUGHT
AGAINST.
BUT, SUSAN, HE NEVER SENT IT.
>> WELL, THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S REALLY -- IT'S REALLY
POWERFUL TO HEAR.
WE MAY HAVE HAD A SENSE OF A
CONFLICT BETWEEN TRUMP AND MANY
OF THE GENERALS WHO WORKED WITH
HIM, BUT TO HEAR IN THEIR OWN
WORDS THEIR FEAR THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WAS IN EFFECT A ROGUE PRESIDENT,
THAT HE WAS NOT EVEN A
SUBSCRIBER TO MANY OF THE IDEALS
OF THE CONSTITUTION.
AFTER LAFAYETTE SQUARE, THAT WAS
A MISTAKE, THAT WAS A BIG
DISASTER IN MANY WAYS FOR MARK
MILLEY, THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS AND THE THEN
DEFENSE SECRETARY MARK ESPER
MARCHING THROUGH LAFAYETTE
SQUARE.
IT GAVE THE APPEARANCE OF THE
MILITARY PARTICIPATING IN
POLITICS.
HE APOLOGIZED FOR IT, BUT HE WAS
AGONIZED ACCORDING TO OUR
REPORTING ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
TO RESIGN.
CONSULTED WITH MANY WHO SAID,
LISTEN, WE DON'T HAVE A
TRADITION OF RESIGNATION IN
PROTEST FOR OUR UNIFORMED
MILITARY AND THAT IT WOULD
ACTUALLY BE MORE IMPORTANT TO
REMAIN IN OFFICE.
REMEMBER, THIS IS SIX MONTHS
BEFORE JANUARY 6.
SO TO READ THOSE WORDS NOW WHEN
WE KNOW ABOUT THE CATACLYSMIC
ENDING OF THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
THIS IS A THROUGH LINE WE FOUND
IN OUR REPORTING GOING ALL THE
WAY BACK TO THE BEGINNING OF THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY, THE CONFLICTS
WITH THE GENERALS, CURRENT AND
FORMER, BEGAN ALMOST FROM DAY
ONE OF THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY
BECAUSE TRUMP WAS DETERMINED TO
CHALLENGE THEIR CONVENTIONS.
AT ONE POINT A SENIOR GENERAL
EVEN TOLD HIM THAT'S WHAT
DICTATORS DO, TO SOMETHING TRUMP
WANTED TO DO.
>> THAT'S A HELL OF A
RESIGNATION LETTER.
MARK MILLEY DIDN'T SEND IT, BUT
HE LISTS OUT THE THINGS THERE.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE TO ME THAT
HE EVEN THOUGHT ABOUT SENDING
THAT AND I GUESS WE CAN DEBATE
FOR GENERATIONS ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT IT WOULD HAVE HAD A BIGGER
IMPACT HAD HE QUIT AT THE TIME.
SUSAN, SOME OTHER NEWS FROM YOU
IN THIS BOOK WITH PETER BAKER,
YOUR HUSBAND, WHERE TRUMP IS
QUOTED AS TELLING HIS
GENERALS -- AND I WILL READ
THIS -- YOU EFFING GENERALS, WHY
CAN'T YOU BE LIKE THE GERMAN
GENERALS, WHICH GENERALS, JOHN
KELLY ASKED, AND THEN TRUMP SAID
THE GERMAN GENERALS IN WORLD WAR
II.
THAT IN AND OF ITSELF
INTERESTING AND MAYBE DISTURBING
TO SOME PEOPLE BUT THEN IT WENT
ON FROM THERE, A LITTLE BIT OF A
HISTORY LESSON, SUSAN.
>> YOU KNOW, JOHN, IT'S
BREATHTAKING, HONESTLY.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS A
CONFRONTATION, A CONVERSATION
BETWEEN THE THEN WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF JOHN KELLY AND
DONALD TRUMP AND, YOU KNOW, YOU
ALMOST CAN'T BELIEVE IT, BUT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WAS UNHAPPY BECAUSE HE FELT THAT
HIS GENERALS AS HE CALLED THEM,
THE AMERICAN GENERALS, WERE NOT
AS LOYAL AS HE PERCEIVED THE
NAZI GENERALS UNDER HITLER TO
BE.
HE THOUGHT THAT WAS THE BETTER
MODEL FOR A GENERAL.
NOW, JOHN KELLY AS YOU SAID
SCHOOLED TRUMP AND TRIED TO SAY,
WELL, WAIT A MINUTE, MR.
PRESIDENT, THEY WEREN'T
COMPLETELY SUBSERVIENT AND THEY
TRIED TO HILL HITLER THREE TIMES
AND TRUMP INTERRUPTED HIM AND
SAID THAT'S NOT RIGHT, THEY WERE
COMPLETELY LOYAL.
SHOCKING.
>> IT IS SHOCKING.
AND THE POLITICIZATION OF THE
MILITARY WHICH MILLEY TALKS
ABOUT IN HIS RESIGNATION LETTER
THAT HE NEVER SENT, THE FACT
THAT THE MILITARY IS SUPPOSED TO
BE APOLITICAL IS A HALLMARK OF
AMERICAN SOCIETY AND IT'S SO
INTERESTING YOU'RE DESCRIBING IN
SUCH DETAIL, SUSAN, HOW THE
MILITARY ITSELF WAS FIGHTING TO
PRESERVE THAT AS A CIVILIAN
COMMANDER WAS FIGHTING TO
BASTARDIZE THAT.
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK YOU PUT
YOUR FINGER ON T BRIANNA.
THIS IS LIKE THERE'S NO
HANDBOOK, THERE IS NO GUIDE IN
THE CONSTITUTION FOR WHAT TO DO
WHEN THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF IS A
NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT, AND
THEY BELIEVE -- YOU KNOW, THAT
CIVIL MILITARY RELATIONSHIP IS
ALMOST A RELIGION FOR THE MOST
SENIOR GENERALS, AS YOU KNOW, IN
OUR MILITARY AND I THINK THIS
CONFLICT -- AGAIN, THE THROUGH
LINE -- THIS DID NOT START AFTER
THE NOVEMBER 2020 ELECTION,
RIGHT?
THERE WERE THESE CONFLICTS ABOUT
THE ROLE IN THE MILITARY, TRUMP
WANTED TO CLOAK HIMSELF IN THE
POWER AND THE PHOTO OPS AND WHAT
HE PERCEIVED TO BE THE STRENGTH
OF THE MILITARY FROM DAY ONE OF
HIS PRESIDENCY AND, YOU KNOW,
WHAT I WAS STRUCK BY IS THE
RECURRING THEME OF THIS.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S A FIGHT WITH
THE GENERALS IN THE FIRST SUMMER
OF HIS PRESIDENCY OVER A
MILITARY PARADE.
THAT WAS WHAT I WAS MENTIONING
ABOUT THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF IN THE
OVAL OFFICE TELLING HIM, NO, MR.
PRESIDENT, WE CAN'T DO THE KIND
OF PARADE YOU WANT.
THAT'S WHAT DICTATORS DO.
RIGHT THERE IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
SO IT WAS A CONFLICT FROM DAY
ONE.
>> WHAT OTHER JUICY TIDBITS ARE
GOING TO BE OUT IN THIS BOOK?
WE ARE JUST GETTING A TASTE OF
IT NOW IN "THE NEW YORKER," BUT
WHAT ELSE DO YOU HAVE IN THERE?
>> WELL, IT'S COMING SOON, BUT,
LOOK, IT'S VERY -- THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT.
WE FELT THAT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
DO A BOOK ON THE FOUR YEARS OF
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY AND TO
REALLY TRY TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS THREAT TO DEMOCRACY AFTER
THE 2020 ELECTION DID NOT COME
OUT OF NOWHERE AND IN SOME WAYS
GOING BACK TO THE EARLY YEARS OF
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION THERE
WERE SOME EXTRAORDINARY THINGS
THAT NEVER BECAME PUBLIC THAT
HELPED TO UNDERSTAND THE MESS
THAT IT ALL ENDED UP IN.
>> IT'S SO INTERESTING.
THERE'S THIS WHOLE ACADEMIC
REALM OF CIVILIAN MILITARY
RELATIONS.
IT CAN BE KIND OF LOFTY, BUT WE
SAW IT ALL PLAY OUT IN VERY REAL
TERMS UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND HERE YOU ARE
WRITING THIS FANTASTIC BOOK
TAKING US THROUGH ALL OF IT.
SUSAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND THE BOOK OF COURSE IS "THE
DIVIDER" AND YOU CAN PICK THAT
UP SOON.
>> THIS FALL.